[MUSIC PLAYING]
MISHA BRUKMAN: Welcome
everyone to the session.
My name is Misha Brukman.
I'm the product manager
for Google Cloud Bigtable.
And with us today,
we have Leon Stein
from eBay, who will talk
about how eBay brings together
billions of product listings to
enable new shopping experiences
using Google Cloud Bigtable.
Leon--
LEON STEIN: Hi.
So first, a few
facts about eBay.
eBay is a truly global company.
We have 167 million buyers
in over 200 countries
all over the world.
Over 57% of our business
is international.
And we are pretty big on
mobile with close to half
of business coming from mobile
and 348 million mobile app
downloads.
Other brands of eBay include
eBay Classifieds and StubHub.
So at the heart of what
eBay does is eBay catalog.
And eBay catalog is
pretty big and it's
very rich and very complex.
So we have well over 1
billion listings available
worldwide in eBay catalog
at any given moment.
And over 15 million listings are
added to the catalog every day.
And catalog is comprised
of many different datasets,
coming from many
different data sources.
So if you look at
an eBay listing,
you will see obvious things
like Title, Price, Variance,
Description, Attributes, Images.
But there are also many data
elements that are not visible.
And they are computed
behind the scenes,
by many different algorithms
to enhance selling and buying
experience.
So it's not unusual for an
eBay listing to take megabytes,
not counting images.
And of course the volume of
updates of eBay catalog is--
of various datasets in
eBay catalog is very high,
and we will talk more about it.
So with our team, which is
New Product Development team,
and we build applications
on Google Cloud Platform.
First thing we wanted to
bring over is the catalog.
And we needed a
scalable platform
to effectively enable new
shopping experiences globally,
showcasing eBay inventory.
We wanted a platform that allows
us to scale on demand with data
volume and traffic.
We wanted to be able to
iterate quickly and integrate
with data-heavy AI technologies.
Our first application that
we launched this last October
is eBay ShopBot.
So you can go--
if you happen to have a
mobile device or a laptop--
you can go to shopbot.ebay.com
and start playing with it.
So eBay ShopBot is a new--
is a newer, smarter, and easier
way to shop in chatbot context.
And it leverages AI with NLU,
dialog management, and also
visual search.
So you can snap a picture of
an item you're interested in
and submit it to ShopBot
and you will hopefully
find something very close.
So there are a number of
challenges, of course,
with bringing all that data
over to Google Cloud platform.
First, the catalog
had to be brought
from many different sources.
And we wanted to bring
it in a way that is
really convenient to work with.
So that instead of having
different pieces of catalog
in different systems, we wanted
to have all data effectively
together, so it's
much easier to work
with it in different contexts
and enable different shopping
use cases.
So we also needed
to provide a highly
scalable and consistently fast
way of accessing catalog data.
We have hundreds of
thousands of updates
per second on
catalog data with is
hundreds of megabytes written,
and very high volume reads.
For example, an update to
catalog results in search index
update.
And in order to re-index
a listing in real time,
you need to know
more information
about the listing than
happened with just that update.
So we have more reads in
terms of volume than writes.
So our reads are in many
gigabytes per second.
And of course we
wanted very low latency
replicating catalog data
from eBay core system
to Google Cloud platform.
So that it is important
in retail domain
to have up-to-date data.
So if listing is no
longer available,
we don't want to show it.
If price changes, we want
to show updated price.
And we also needed very high
consistency of the data.
So that we-- in case
if an update is missed
in near real time, we
still want to make sure
that we have a mechanisms
that repairs this data,
so the replicated
data is eventually
correct and consistent
with what we have in core.
So for example, if price
changes or listing got bought
and we didn't catch
this event, we
want to have a
mechanism in place that
ensures that we will have
data eventually correct
in Google platform.
So about Google Cloud platform--
it is-- there are
many great features
and I just want to highlight a
few of them that we leverage.
It is first-- it
is global presence,
which eBay as a global company,
needs a platform that allows--
that supports global
presence really well.
Also comprehensive and highly
coherent technology stack.
And-- we are cutting edge.
We like to work with
newest technologies
and GCP provides those
new technologies for us.
And it has leading
support for Kubernetes
with Container Engine.
And we leverage Kubernetes
in many of our services,
so it was very important to us.
And finally, there are some
unique offerings in GCP.
There are many of
them, but for this talk
I want to focus
on Bigtable, that
was the data storage that
we've selected for the catalog.
And we will go in more detail
on how we use Bigtable.
With that-- so this is
a high-level diagram
that just covers our
data injection pipeline.
It doesn't cover our whole
infrastructure on GCP.
It's much bigger,
but this is just
the part that is responsible
for getting that catalog
from eBay core systems to GCP.
And in the next
slides, we will go
in more detail in parts of it.
And with that, I'll
pass it back to Misha
for a deeper dive in
GCP and the systems
MISHA BRUKMAN: Before we talk
about Google Cloud Platform
in more detail, I
thought it would
be worthwhile to look at
the history of Google,
and where Google comes from,
and how we arrived to the point
that we are today.
Google originally set out
to organize the world's
information and
make it universally
accessible and useful.
And for that, Google
built web search.
Now, that is a very
specific application.
There is a lot of very
search-specific algorithms
and details that go
on behind the scenes.
But even with this very
specific application,
Google had to solve a
number of very generic,
standard, big data problems,
to be able to enable the search
application service.
For one, we had to be able to
store a large amount of data.
And depending on the type
and the content of the data,
we need to use a
different storage
system for those
different types of data.
So we needed to use
file systems, databases,
and other types of
storage systems.
Once we had that
data, we needed to be
able to process it at scale.
And we needed to both be able
to process that data in batch
mode, to analyze the link
structure of the worldwide web,
as well to update data in real
time as pull up pages changed.
So we needed a real-time
streaming pipeline as well.
And then to be able
to serve the data,
we needed to be able to deploy
and update our services,
and we use a micro
service architecture.
We needed to update them quickly
and without any downtime.
Google built a number of generic
infrastructure components.
And with that, it enabled
a number of teams,
across many different
domains within Google,
to build a number of
services that each of which
serve over a billion users.
So each of the services that
you see featured on this slide,
from Google itself, Google.com,
to Google Play, Chrome,
Android, YouTube, Maps, Gmail,
and Google Cloud Platform.
Each of those serve
over a billion users.
And the way that we've
been able to do that
is by using similar
architecture and infrastructure
components across all of them.
So all of these services
benefit from the same hardware
infrastructure, networking,
the global network
that we have built, to enable
them to operate at the scale
that they do.
Not only the hardware,
but also the software.
Over the years, Google has built
a number of software components
to enable all those
projects to scale.
Starting with file
systems such as GFS,
on to processing systems
such as MapReduce, Flume,
and MillWheel, to analytic
systems like Dremel,
databases like
Spanner and Bigtable,
and container
managers like Borg.
Google has been able to build
these generic systems such
that each of those teams were
able to innovate and build
the domain-specific
components that they needed
for their services without
having to reinvent and resolve
the standard big data
problems that they would all
face consistently.
And now with all of these
technologies that Google
has built over the
years to support
all of its own products,
we're making all of them
available on Google Cloud
Platform in the various areas
of Compute, Storage,
Databases, Big Data Processing,
and Machine Learning.
So that anyone can use
these building blocks
to build their own applications
and their own services
and have them seamlessly
scale to serve
millions and billions of users.
Let's talk about a couple of
these components in more depth.
So for one, as I
mentioned, we needed
to be able to run systems.
And we needed to upgrade
these systems very quickly
and efficiently
with no downtime.
Google started off by
building container support
by writing the cgroup
support, that we
open sourced and contributed
to Linux, over a decade ago.
But we also needed
to be able to run
these containers as workloads.
So we built Borg
and then we open
sourced a container
manager called Kubernetes.
And now we've created a
managed service offering
that uses Kubernetes-- and this
is Google Container Engine.
Container Engine provides
cluster management
and orchestration for your
container as workloads.
It also provides a private
container registry for you
to deploy your applications.
Applications can use a
declarative specification
for resources that
Kubernetes and Container
Engine will enforce.
And it also provides
auto-scaling to meet the needs
of growing applications.
We also needed to have
a file system that
would scale to the growing
needs of the internet.
And so we started off was--
we built Google File
System, and then we've
upgraded that with Colossus.
And today we offer
that as a service,
as Google Cloud Storage.
Google Cloud Storage is an
exabyte-scale storage system.
It provides high-throughput.
It provides replicated
storage across regional and
multi-regional modes.
It also provides
several different types
of classes for your
data, depending
on whether your data is hot or
cold, or somewhere in-between.
And it uses the same API, so you
don't have to change your code,
depending on which type
of data you're accessing.
It also provides an
HDFS-compatible connector
for Hadoop, so you don't have
to change your code if you
are using Hadoop with HDFS.
Two It will work seamlessly
with Google Cloud Storage, again
across all those
different storage classes
and different bucket types.
Once we have the
data, we need to be
able to process that at scale.
And we're talking about both
static and streaming data.
Google has written
several different systems
from batch to streaming,
such as MapReduce, Flume,
and MillWheel.
And then we combined
all of those together,
to offer as a single product,
Google Cloud Dataflow.
Then we went a step
further, and we've open
sourced the SDK behind Google
Cloud Dataflow as Apache Beam.
Apache Beam recently
became a top level project
in the Apache
Software Foundation.
Dataflow combines both
batch and streaming modes.
So you don't have to change
your code from one to the other.
You can write your
code once, and you
can run the same code in both
batch and streaming modes.
Dataflow provides
auto-scaling and dynamic task
sharding so that you're not
affected by long stragglers
doubling or tripling the
total length of your job.
As Dataflow notices
that some of the workers
are struggling to
process the data,
it will dynamically
split those data
and then autoscale and
provide more workers
to handle those shards that
are taking longer than others.
Dataflow provides connectors
to our various storage systems,
such as BigQuery Bigtable,
and Cloud Storage,
so you can read and
write data from anywhere.
And as I mentioned, code that
uses the open source Apache
Beam SDK also becomes portable.
You can run Apache Beam
workloads on Dataflow,
as well as Spark and Flink.
We also wanted to be able to
run open source processing
engines, such as Hadoop
and Spark, directly.
So for that, we built
Google Cloud Dataproc.
Dataproc allows you to run
could Hadoop, Spark, Pig, Hive,
and other open source
big data systems.
It also provides connectors
to Bigtable, BigQuery,
and Google Cloud Storage.
So again, you can read
and write from anywhere.
And because it can read and
write data from anywhere,
you don't have to write
in stateless clusters.
Instead, you can run
stateless clusters
that have their storage
external to them.
Which means you can
very quickly and easily
spin-up clusters, run
the jobs that you need,
and spin them down.
Dataproc also provides
a higher level jobs
API, such that you
can just submit jobs,
rather than thinking
about clusters--
long-running clusters
managing those clusters.
We also needed to have a
petabyte-scale database.
When we used to build our search
indexes in batch mode in bulk,
it took a long time to keep
rebuilding the entire search
index.
It also made the index
grow stale over time
because we would
not be able to catch
the really quickly changing
web pages as they changed
in real time.
So what we needed was a
real-time, low latency,
access to data sets
scaled into the petabytes.
And for that, we wrote Bigtable.
And we're now
offering of Bigtable,
as Google Cloud Bigtable, as a
fully managed service on Google
Cloud platform.
Bigtable is a fully
managed NoSQL database.
As I mentioned, it provides
petabyte scale data scale
storage with low latency access
for both reads and writes.
It provides very seamless
scalability for throughput
and it learns and adjusts
to access patterns.
Let's look into more detail
about those last two points
and how we provide that.
So first let's talk
about the structure
and the schema for Bigtable.
Bigtable is a NoSQL, sparse,
wide-column database.
So what that means is that
Bigtable has a single key,
which is the row key.
It does not do joins and it only
does single row transactions.
It's sparse, so that
means that whenever
you don't store the data
in any one of the cells,
it does not count
against the storage.
It is wide-column,
which means that you
can create column families.
And within each
column family, you
can create, essentially, an
unlimited number of columns.
So you can store any
number of data items, keyed
to a single row, as you need.
The way to think about of
Bigtable, as a data model,
is as a three-dimensional
spreadsheet.
There are rows.
There are columns.
And each one of the cell
has an arbitrary number
of versions which are keyed
with a 64-bit integer.
You can treat that
64-bit integer as time,
and that is a very
common use case.
But you could also treat that
as just an arbitrary version
and just assign them
versions as 1, 2, and 3.
Bigtable is an unopinionated
storage system.
So you can store
any type of data.
It's uninterpreted so
they're just bytes.
And there are many
different applications
that can be built
on top of Bigtable.
However, for each
one of those, you
would have to design
custom row key schemas.
For a number of
standard use cases,
there are open source systems
that already predefine
those schemas such that you
can implement these common use
cases very easily.
So Bigtable has need of
support for a time series,
because it has that
third dimension of time.
But you would still
have to carefully design
your time series schema to make
sure that it performs well.
Or you can use one of
the open source systems,
such as Heroic by
Spotify, or OpenTSTB,
which is an open source
time series database.
In fact, Spotify runs their
monitoring system today
on Bigtable using
the Heroic system.
Alternatively, if
you need to run
graph workloads-- of course, you
can implement a graph schema,
using something like
adjacency lists,
using the wide-column database.
You can also use one of these
two graph abstraction systems,
such as HgraphDb or
JanusGraph, to provide you
with a standard, tinker pop
API implementation on top
of Bigtable.
JanusGraph is something that
we just launched recently,
in cooperation with several
other companies, IBM,
Hortonworks, Expero and GRAKN.
This is a new project,
as of two months ago,
in the Linux Foundation that
is now working with Bigtable.
It also supports other open
source wide-column databases.
Let's talk about the
Bigtable implementation
and the architecture behind it.
So this is a somewhat
simplified architecture,
and we're going to go into
depth in the next few slides.
Clients connect to a load
balancing proxy endpoint which
then connect to the processing
nodes of Bigtable server nodes.
In the next few
slides, I'm going
to remove the load balancing
proxy layer, for clarity,
to show where the requests
are actually routed.
But just remember that
there is a single endpoint,
so there is no need
for a discovery
service for each client to
know where to connect to.
All the clients connect
to a single endpoint.
One interesting
thing about Bigtable
is that as a database, Bigtable
itself is actually stateless.
Bigtable does not
store any data.
And this is actually true
for all the other big Google
storage systems.
Bigtable, Spanner, BigQuery,
and Google Cloud Storage
all use the Colossus
file system.
So Bigtable nodes
provide you with access,
and they mediate the
requests between the clients
and the data.
But the Bigtable
nodes themselves
don't store any data.
Now this provides a couple
interesting features
as to how Bigtable operates.
Let's say we are
looking at an access
pattern such as the one
in the diagram, where
the Bigtable node on
the left is getting more
requests than the other nodes.
And that is because it is
managing the data in Colossus,
the regions A, B, and
C, and that data appears
to be popular with the clients.
As Bigtable noticed
that one of the nodes
is getting more
activity than others,
it can easily reassign
the ownership of that data
to a different node.
And the request would be
rerouted automatically.
Again, remember there is that
load balancing proxy layer.
This is possible to do quickly
because we're not actually
moving any of the data.
None of the nodes
actually store the data
within their own containers.
So this is just a
metadata reassignment,
which happens very quickly.
We don't need to copy
terabytes or petabytes of data
to be able to do
this re-assignment,
so this happens very quickly.
In fact, this
happens all the time.
So for example, if you
wanted to scale the cluster,
the same thing happens.
It's very easy and
seamless to scale clusters,
because again, we're only
moving the re-assignment.
Now, remember that each node
has to have exclusive access
to the data that it's managing,
because we're providing
atonic single row transactions.
This means that you can
easily scale the clusters up.
But this also means that you can
easily scale the clusters down.
So if you know that you need
to do some workloads that
will change in the size and
type and nature of the workload,
you can easily send
an API request,
resize the cluster up, do
your additional processing
with data PROC or data
flow or any other system,
and then scale it down.
And Bigtable will handle the
management automatically.
One interesting thing
that also happens
is with Bigtable, the throughput
scales linearly in proportion
to the number of nodes.
For one, because it's very
easy to scale the clusters.
And because the nodes themselves
don't talk to each other.
They're completely independent.
The throughput
scales in proportion
to the number of nodes.
In many other storage
systems, this performance
would typically flatten
out after a while.
But with Bigtable,
it scales linearly.
So whether you have 3,
30, 300 or more nodes,
the throughput and processing
will scale linearly.
Last year we did a test
with one of our customers
with 3500 Bigtable
nodes and 232 VMs,
and again, the throughput
there scales linearly.
At this point, I'll
pass it back to Leon
to talk about the architecture
that you saw earlier,
in more depth.
LEON STEIN: Thanks, Misha.
So going back to our eBay
use case and our challenges--
so we had to synchronize a
catalog over to Google Cloud
platform in near real-time
with low latency--
we're talking about single
seconds of latency--
and with high consistency.
So we also want to
serve the catalog data
to other services
that consume it
on Google Cloud
Platform with high read
volume and low latency.
And we also want to support
the vision use case.
So we want to keep listing
images in Google Cloud Platform
for training vision models.
And also, we want to keep
AI vision signatures, which
are feature vectors
over images somewhere,
so that we can extract and build
image search index out of them.
So we've selected Bigtable
to store catalog data, which
may sound unusual.
It's not like Misha mentioned.
Bigtable is
unopinionated datastore.
So it worked really well for us.
It is highly scalable
and reliable solution.
And with amount of data and
volume of updates and reads,
it was a store that
could handle this.
It has excellent performance.
And another important
consideration
for us is the API, the
Java API, to Bigtable
is actually based
on HBase client.
So if you don't
know about HBase,
Apache's HBase is open
source NoSQL database
that was modeled after Google
published Bigtable paper.
So HBase was modeled after
Bigtable, and the ideas
that Apache Bigtable
utilizes are the ones that
were used by Bigtable.
And it's very nice
that Google chose
to implement [INAUDIBLE]
client as fully
compatible HBase client.
So you can write code
against Bigtable,
as you would write
it against HBase.
So compared to HBase and another
very popular NoSQL database,
Cassandra, is the
performance of Bigtable
is significantly higher.
So in addition it is
fully managed, of course,
on Google Cloud Platform.
So while Cassandra
and HBased deployments
are nontrivial to support,
and especially at large scale,
it is well integrated with GCP
console and rest of the Google
Cloud Platform stack.
As Misha mentioned, there
are connectors from Dataproc,
Dataflow.
So-- and going back
to performance,
this chart shows a benchmark
that actually Google
made a couple of years ago,
comparing Bigtable performance
to HBase and Cassandra.
And you can see that the writes
and reads is where Bigtable
consistently takes six
milliseconds operation,
and HBase and Cassandra are
in hundreds of milliseconds.
Well, Cassandra does better on--
obviously on writes,
because that's
what it was optimized for.
So another great
features of Bigtable
is seamless cluster resizing.
So we run pretty large Bigtable
instance on hundreds of nodes,
but sometimes we need
to make bulk loads that
require much more resources.
And we can add 100's
or a few hundred
nodes to our Bigtable instance.
And in 20 minutes, it is all
re-balanced and ready to go
and we can send the
load to Bigtable.
And then after we are done,
we can remove this nodes
and it just continues going.
We don't see any
degradation in performance
as re-balancing is happening.
It's works really, really great.
Also, the administrative
operations against Bigtable,
like adding new tables,
changing column families,
they're all nonblocking
and they can done
on running Bigtable instance.
And again, there is no effect
on running applications.
Finally, a lot of
magic, I guess,
as we been working with
Bigtable for the last year,
we realized that a lot
of magic with performance
goes into the client.
And Google is actively working
on open source Bigtable client.
And we were really happy
with all the optimizations
that we've seen that went into
the client over the past year,
and we are sure it will
continue going this way.
So back to the diagram.
So this is the
diagram at high level.
You can see is that we use many
different components on GCP
platform just to support
catalog ingestion.
So let's focus on our
near-real-time synchronization
pipeline.
So in eBay core on
the left, you see
we have our private cloud,
where we have Compute, Storage,
and Streaming, where data
is originally hosted.
So we have exposed
all the updates
that go to different data sets
that comprise eBay catalog.
We have exposed them
as Kafka streams.
So there are dozens
of different datasets
that compose eBay listings,
which are partitioned
across many Kafka streams.
So we are dealing with close
to 500 individual streams.
And this streams are
consumed by storm typologies
that we manage and
run on eBay side.
If we probably would
have considered
Apache Beam for that.
But we have storm typologies
that consumes this events.
It aggregates them
in micro batches,
does duplications, and then
sends this micro batches over
to GCP.
We use Google Cloud load
balancer right at France--
Kubernetes cluster of
our catalog service--
that receives this
micro batches--
and micro batches may
contain anywhere from 1
to a few hundred records--
and then insert
them into Bigtable.
So now let's look
at the table that--
where we store that data.
So we chose to store the
data in the original format
that we get from core.
And the reason for
that is we want
to be really flexible in
how we expose this data.
So the most flexibility
for us would
be not to make any
changes to raw data,
but rather have a separate table
where we convert and transform
the data.
So having data in the
original format in GCP
gives us the ability to go
back and recompute our target
model at any point of time.
The data sets that
we got from core are
included in Apache avro format.
So every cell here
actually contains
a record with multiple fields
that are encoded in avro.
We have a separate table
where we store avro schemas,
so we don't lose track of those.
And you can see that we have
multiple column families.
So in fact, for
every dataset we use,
we have a separate
column family.
And that helps us isolating
the load on Bigtable because--
the nice thing about
column families
is that if you have
independent reads--
so if you read or write to
a particular column family,
it doesn't feel as
a column families.
So you can have
many of them, you
can have hundreds of column
families, but you only--
you need to writes or reads
only ones that you touch matter.
So in every column family
we have two columns.
One for meta data, that
captures information
on where the record originated
from, some correlation,
identifiers.
Some of the streams
that we consume
come from Oracle
Golden Gate, so it
will capture Oracle row ids,
transaction commit sequences,
and whatnot.
And then the avro records
that contains the data itself.
So you will also notice
that we have NRT,
the column family prefix
is NRT, which stands
for near-real-time, and DW.
So we'll cover it later.
For some data sets,
these are duplicated.
So the DW are coming from Batch.
And I'll explain
later why we do that.
Now going to row key design--
as I mentioned,
listings are comprised
on many different
kinds of records.
And you can look at it as
hierarchical parent-child data
structure.
So if you have a
listing 1, 2, 3,
it may have variance 1 and 2.
So we prefix the key
by the listing ID.
Then we put colon
qualifier for the kind
of child we are
writing, and then
colon and then the
identifier for that child.
And then if you
have grandchildren,
we'll keep appending to the key.
So that allows us to keep
all the records belonging
to the same listing
together, which
is really important
with Bigtable,
because they can be scanned
together really efficiently.
So Bigtable allows
scanning by key prefix
and this records are
physically stored together,
so you can read
them really quickly.
Now with key design,
it is really important
to avoid hot spotting,
which is having
keys that are monotonically
increasing or decreasing.
So with eBay listings, we
do not have exactly that,
but the distribution of keys
of listing identifiers in eBay
is not exactly uniform.
So we chose to reverse
lexicographically
the listing IDs.
And that makes
distribution uniform
and avoids any
potential interference
with how the data is
distributed in Bigtable
and how it is scanned.
And you also notice
that these gray cells
contain no data, which
is fine because Bigtable
doesn't punish you for
having sparse data sets.
So you don't pay, you don't--
if data is not there,
it doesn't take space.
So as a NoSQL database, Bigtable
supports a retrieval by keys.
So if you have a key,
you can get the value,
or you can scan a key range.
These are basically two
different fundamental axis
patterns with Bigtable.
So you cannot have secondary
indices supplied by Bigtable
itself, but you can make one
for yourself as another table
in Bigtable.
And we use that, since
we need to know--
we have accumulated over a year
or so that we have been running
on Google Cloud Platform--
we've accumulated
billions of listings
and 100's of terabytes
of data in Bigtable.
However, it is really
important for us
to know which listings
are available right now,
which is about 1.1 billion.
And we want to scan the
listings that are available
right now really quickly.
For example if you
want to rebuild
search index from scratch
or to run some reporting.
So for that we maintain
a separate table, which
is really small
or really narrow,
that only contains
the identifiers
of the available listings.
So if listing
becomes unavailable,
we just delete a
record from Bigtable.
Or if we get a new
listing that is available,
we just add a record here.
And the identifiers,
the listing identifiers
are prefixed here by site IDs.
And site IDs stands
pretty much for market
where item was listed,
United States, UK, and so on.
This allows us to scan just for
available listings in United
States, or just for
available listings for UK.
So we can rebuild the index
just for the subset of markets
that we want to.
And then we have a few columns.
In this case, we add seller_id
and leaf category ID,
in case if you want to
do additional filtering,
as we scan this data
without having to do lookups
against all listings table.
Now the value of--
so as I mentioned,
the values that you
want to bring to the stack of
applications that use catalog,
is by representing eBay catalog
in a coherent, convenient way
to other applications.
So we've developed schema,
or data structure that
represents eBay catalog,
which is much more convenient
than the raw data that we get.
So we store the data
in a separate table
and we chose protobuffers
to represent that schema.
And we also break
it up into fragments
that we store across
column families
so that we can retrieve them
separately for efficiency.
So in case if you only need
to know about variance,
you can just scan
that column family.
We use-- here, each record
contains a single listing ID--
each record contains
single listing,
so the keys are
lexicographically
reversed listing IDs.
And we also have this
src_version column
that we use for lazy
rebuilding catalog model.
So usually we rebuild catalog
model as we ingest new data.
But in some cases when
we do batch operation,
we can just implement
the version in this table
without rebuilding
the whole model.
So next time we need
to read, we knows
that the model that we have
in this table is stale,
and we need to rebuild it.
So next, the Catalog service.
So Catalog service is running--
or as I mentioned on
Kubernetes on Container Engine,
we've chosen to front all access
to Bigtable by this service.
So that clients that need
to deal with Catalog data,
they have to go through
Catalog service.
They don't have to
deal with intricacies
of Bigtable storage.
And this service,
you can imagine,
it runs on pretty large
number of instances
because it gets a lot of read
and write hits from all over.
And Container Engine
really helps us
with managing deployments and
scaling of our Catalog service.
We have it fully integrated
in continuous delivery
pipeline that we run on Core.
And we write our images to
Container Registry in Google
Cloud Platform and do
rollouts in managed way,
so it doesn't impact the
capacity of our service.
So it's been working
really, really well.
So this service is
processing many thousands
of batches per second,
with every batch containing
hundreds of records, so it's
pretty heavy volume service.
Now I've mentioned that
we needed the mechanism
to ensure that we
don't miss updates.
Our near-real-time pipeline is
designed not to miss updates.
So if for some reason we
cannot write to Bigtable,
we'll just go into this infinite
retrial loop, and then alert,
and then someone has to come
in and fix the pipeline so that
updates keep flowing.
But it happens that upstream
we might miss an event
just because something
happened up stream from us.
So for that-- and also
to support datasets
that are not available
in near-real-time,
we've added a Batch pipeline.
So Batch pipeline
synchronizes some
of the main datasets about
the eBay catalog that
contain price and
availability information,
and we do it daily.
So in case if we missed
price or availability update
at the end of the day, we'll
catch it with a batch update,
and reconcile it.
And so this inconsistency,
we'll leave in our catalog
for up to a day.
We also have a dashboard
for highly visible items.
We can compare what is in Core
systems to what is in Bigtable,
and then force synchronization.
Now the way Batch
pipeline works--
first, we have--
of course much data
is extracted from our Hadoop
and Teradata data warehouses
that run in Core.
And then this extracts
that rerun data
broken into many small fragments
containing up to a few million
of records.
And we load this batches
over to Google Cloud Platform
and we put them in
Google Cloud Storage.
And after each fragment
is transferred,
we invoke a call
to Catalog service
so that it can load it
from Google Cloud Storage
and stream it from Google
Cloud Storage and stream
this batch into Bigtable.
This operation is
very important.
So if something breaks, we
can repeat until we succeed.
And we keep track of
all the fragments,
both on Core, in a
simple SQL database so we
can account for each fragment.
So we make sure that everything
is loaded completely.
And we also keep track
of this batch operations
on Bigtable side, so that our
load operation is effectively
nonblocking.
So we just make a
call to load and then
we pull against HTTP
API of Catalog service
to check whether the
fragment is loaded,
which may take from a few
seconds to couple of minutes.
So next part is
integration with Search.
So Search is really
the main consumer
of catalog data
for us, so it has
to reindex listings in real time
as listing information changes.
In the retail world, you
have to index in real time.
We've chosen to put Pub/Sub
between our search index
build and our
catalog service, just
to give a little
room for our index
build process to
adjust to spikes
in the number of updates.
So if there is a big spike,
Pub/Sub will buffer it,
and Search can work
at its own pace.
Search indexing can
work at its own pace.
The way it works, as data is
pushed to Catalog service,
is the identifiers of the
listings that are affected,
along with some meta
data that tells which
dataset this update is coming
from, and actually in a bitmap
containing the
indices of columns
that got touched by that
update, is put on Pub/Sub.
So each message may
contain a number
of listings corresponding
to the micro batch,
along with the meta data.
So search index build
consumes this messages
from Pub/Sub topic.
And based on what
changed about listings,
it decides what it needs to
fetch from Catalog service.
It usually needs to fetch more
than just the dataset that
changed, because
indexing involves
pretty complex
operations that requires
knowing a lot about listing.
But in certain cases,
it can just take--
it just needs to know a
subset of listing data,
and really helps
us with reducing
the load against Catalog
Service and Bigtable.
So that is pretty much how our
near-real-time search indexing
works.
So next, as I mentioned, our
ShopBot supports image search.
You snap a picture, or
use an existing picture.
You give it to
ShopBot, and it finds
items that are available
that looks similarly.
It works really well.
It is a image
search that we have.
The image models are
developed in-house.
In fact, we've just
submitted-- a couple
of weeks ago-- submitted
a paper to KDD 2017
where we describe in detail
how we build our image models
and how our pipelines and
image search works, in detail.
So if you're interested,
please ping me
offline and I can give you
more information about that.
So our Catalog
service in Bigtable
will ultimately
participate in the process
of helping enable image search.
So what happens is, as
we get catalog data,
we detect if we have new images,
or list of images for a listing
changed.
So in response, we download
images from eBay Core.
We save the images in GCS,
in Google Cloud Storage.
And we also have GPU cluster
where we're on our own vision
models, where we pass the images
to compute feature vectors
representing these images.
And storing these
feature vectors
which are half a megabyte--
512 bytes-- half a Kilobyte
records to Bigtable.
So here is how our
images table looks like.
So it has image unique
identifier as a key.
And it stores a couple of
versions of image signatures.
The reason we store
a couple of versions,
it helps us transitioning from
one vision model to another.
So in case, it helps with
smooth transitioning of that.
Finally we have
another small table
that just keeps image hashes
over the bits of images.
And that helps us the
duplicating the images.
In our business, we find
that quite a lot, about 20%
of images, that
actually duplicates
and they are submitted
under different names.
So this helps us identify if
you already have seen and image
in the past, in that case we
don't save it in Google Cloud
Storage.
It helps us with reducing
our Google Cloud Storage
requirements.
Finally, we do batch
processing against Bigtable.
So this batch processing--
we have several use cases
for batch processing.
One of them is
building image index.
And for that, we need to
scan all available listings,
and we use that
available listings table
that I mentioned that we have,
and then for this listings
we retrieve all the
image signatures
and write them to GCS,
Google Cloud Storage,
and that partitioned
by category.
And then it gets
distributed to a cluster
that serves image searches.
So we use both Cloud
Dataproc and Cloud
Dataflow to scan Bigtable.
It is great support for that.
So just if you've--
best practices and
tricks about Bigtable.
So first, pre-join your data.
If you have many datasets
that share the same key,
it's best to put them
in the same table
and then you can leverage--
and then you scan and
access data together.
You can also leverage atomicity
that transaction support
at row level that Bigtable has.
And then, column families
allow you to separate the load
with different access patterns.
And And then with key design--
First, you need to design a
key to avoid hot spotting,
and we covered
that, and there are
several methods of doing that.
You can use hash of the key.
You can choose
one of the columns
in the dataset as a prefix.
Or like we did, you
can try to reversing
your key lexicographically,
and that may
improve your key distribution.
And also key prefixes help
with optimizing queries,
like we do when we want to scan
listings for specific markets.
And also, you can
use key prefixes
to represent parent-child
relationships.
So finally, we use
Monitoring with Stackdriver.
And that helps us
with this 500 streams
that we need to
babysit and manage.
It helps us keep track of those.
We have custom time series
that we've designed.
And we post our latencies
between when event happened
on eBay Core-side, and
when the record got
inserted in to Bigtable,
and also the volumes.
And this is a snapshot of one
of our Stackdriver dashboards
that shows the
volume of the data.
So you can see-- you probably
cannot see the numbers,
but it has all 500 datasets
here, in one place.
And the top one shows a number
of batches and this lines
that are kind of on the top--
it's about 20,000
every five minutes.
So it's a lot.
We have alerts set
of this monitoring.
So in case of things are
not moving fast enough,
we get an alert and we can get
in and add nodes to Bigtable
or fix things.
With that I pass it back to
Misha for some closing notes.
[APPLAUSE]
MISHA BRUKMAN: So I'd like
to thank very much, Leon.
And we have the folks from eBay,
the team that worked on this,
and also we have some folks
from the Bigtable team.
So thank you very much
everyone for contributing
to this project.
[MUSIC PLAYING]